you are two months into marriage how is
married life for you both i think it's
no surprises or anything i mean things
are going well and we're just enjoying
each other and
just kind of continue to
find our routine and here the holidays
will be upon us so yeah i'm so excited
for you both and obviously so excited to
see the wedding come to life on our
screens with the amy and chris is
happily ever after special it is the one
day that you just really want to make
special because it doesn't last just a
day it will hopefully last
the rest of my
life what can fans expect well i hope
what people see throughout this whole
thing is you know like a love story this
is my second
one and this is chris's first but
i i think you know just the the growth
of our relationship you know through the
episodes and uh
prior seasons and now you know being
able to be
part of this wedding special i mean i i
just hope they see a love story that
has grown has
you know solidified and
and um i don't know just happy and
it you know we all know relationships
take work but
it's so worth it is it true what they
say though that the day just goes by so
quickly were you able to
immerse yourself in that moment for me
and i think for both of us the day just
flew by i i kid around not knowing if
you know those that have that italian
history
you know in their family or jewish or
greek or you know whatever but boy i
wish a wedding could be two days
but it did go by so fast but you know
obviously there were those moments i was
grateful my dad
came i was really appreciated to do the
dance with my dad but our first dance
too you know just walking down that
aisle um i think
you know really wanting to go to every
single person and table
to
you know really thank them for being a
part of our life for celebrating with us
that was probably the hard time because
i think if we could eliminated
everything else i still don't think we'd
have time you know probably to do that
so that was one of the very few regrets
i had uh the following day was that i
felt like i i wasn't able to give all my
friends and family that came to the
wedding enough one-on-one time to you
know thank them and appreciate them
being there it just there just wasn't
enough time and we only had 150 people
but it still didn't feel like we had
enough time to visit with everyone but
uh i'm looking forward to watching uh
the special just so that uh we can
relive it again and maybe see some
things that we missed you know
the kids were there the grandchildren
were there everyone kind of played a
significant role how great was it just
to have everyone in one spot surrounded
by so much love well i was really
appreciative that my kids you know said
yes to having ember be our flower girl
jackson being our ring bearer and i of
course got to see them before all of
that
but i'm a little jealous of chris
because he's there up you know at front
was able to see the two of them walk
down the aisle and i'm like
oh i wish i could have been there just
to see this cuteness you know and
that was the favorite part of the whole
day to watch the grandkids come you know
amber doing the flower girl thing and
yeah and jackson the ring bear you know
amber was cute she's sprinkling flowers
and tossing some on jackson as he's
walking next to her
and then watching you know the bar you
know the music started and the barn
doors open and then amy came out and
that was my first look at her in the
dress she gave me no clues anything
about the dress i didn't know what to
expect but she looked gorgeous and then
it was very special to have her dad uh
hand her over to me that was uh that
whole
march you know the the kids and then her
from
the barn up to
uh the gazebo where we did our nuptials
that was that was the favorite part of
the day for me chris how is it being a
step dad for you to these children and
then also just having the grandchildren
around as well you know the kids are too
way too old to consider me a stepfather
and and uh amy has a special name as a
grandma mimi i don't think i'll ever
have a special day but i'll still be
impressed but i enjoy being a part of
that family and i i'm so grateful that
uh that they've all seemed to accept me
and and uh you know i just look forward
to the the years ahead that uh just
getting closer and and growing together
amy with that being said listening to
him say
such kind heartwarming things right
there i see the smile on your face but
what goes through your mind when you
think of that i mean for me it's it's
just like the cherry on you know the
cake and everything because obviously
um you know going through divorce being
divorced and you know hoping one day you
know i would find that you know special
someone
i i wanted to be somewhat prepared and
mentally prepared that
i may love someone but
it won't be guaranteed that my kids will
like who their mom chose or you know the
grandkids and and stuff so it it i mean
my heart is just overflowing with such
you know thankfulness and love that
you know over the five years that we've
been uh dating and knowing each other
you know the kids have been able to get
to know chris and you know mom's gonna
be okay she picked a great guy and for
them to be
so uh accepting of him and embracing him
within the family
and um and everything i it's i i'm
overjoyed really because family and my
kids are everything to me and to be able
to share that in such a way with chris
and and have him feel like
he's a part of it too because
you know he may say forget this mess
but i'm i'm thankful that he feels he's
a part of it and can be a part of it and
stuff like that so yeah no i'm very
happy that is such a beautiful blessing
right there a lot of thankfulness and
you know you obviously mentioned this is
your second go-around this is your
second marriage is there any wisdom that
you've gained that you're taking with
you on this new journey i think as a
woman and and getting divorced later in
life i feel like i did
i think the one thing that i was very
happy and very proud of and
definitely hung on to well two things
maybe number one was my faith
but number two was
so many women can
look down upon themselves that you know
they're not worthy they're not good
enough you know something must have been
wrong or whatever the reason may be and
and i came out of it it's like
yeah it's it's something that broke it's
something that didn't work out
but um
you know i'm still good i i'm a good
person i have a heart i meant well the
intentions but you know on both our
parts it something got lost along the
way but to end a relationship like that
in the public eye
and still come out
i'm okay with just me
if i never have that opportunity to find
someone
i'm good with me i like being with me
and um and that's not in a selfish way
but it's okay if i travel by myself it's
okay if i go out to dinner by myself or
with friends and stuff so i think the
only thing i can encourage other people
is just to hang on to who you are it is
a journey going through divorce and
getting to the other side and then
getting into a new relationship and now
being married again but you know matt
did play a crucial role helping to get
you to the altar in terms of the
location are you happy with the decision
to wed at roloff farms well you know
roloff farms wasn't always an absolute
no regardless it was kind of like on the
back burner a plan b
type of thing because we did have other
places where we were looking at and then
by time we picked a date those other
places went by the wayside and so roloff
farms rose to the top
but um i mean i should probably have you
say the rest but um to chris's credit
he he really helped me see it in a
different perspective i mean i've raced
my kids there i've been on that farm for
many many years but it's also where we
met it's also where our relationship
grew and and became what it was so
to kind of like solidify it and start
our marriage life with our wedding there
and then
going off into the sunset
uh makes sense
yeah well at one point we kind of had it
narrowed down to two places and my
preference was the farm and we got some
uh pushback uh there were some comments
made by some of her family and her
friends you know saying that no you know
you shouldn't get married on the ex's
property but i felt like i had to remind
them for 30 years it was amy's home too
and so just because it changed hands a
couple months ago
you know those 30 years still count i
felt like she had every right to get
married on that as long as matt offered
she had just as much and i think at the
end of the day it was such a beautiful
special day
i can't imagine anybody else
would think that it should have happened
anywhere else
and now you have little video
evidence that you get to hold on to the
rest of your lives together from your
wedding i'm curious if you've given any
thought to when you might turn off the
cameras because the show has been on for
15 years everyone loves it but
do you still feel that same love and
passion for it that you want to continue
it depends on you know the other family
members and
that that are still a part of it and and
stuff like that i i think the big thing
is if we feel like there's stories to be
told from different perspectives
different you know generations i'm the
grandmother a mom
you know then you have zach and tori
their family and then i have my
grandkids so you know if everyone still
feels like we we still have something to
offer that maybe people would still like
to hear those stories
and if not if we don't then i i think
we'll you know make that decision
you know at the time that it needs to be
made but as far as i'm concerned you
know it it it just keeps going
well we just signed up for two more
seasons and who knows what's going to
happen after that so i think it's for me
it's kind of fun to
to have that video catalog of our
journey our life just to have those
moments that we can watch later when
time passes
so i don't mind carrying on
[Music]